an old acquaintance the Mercedes CLS but
it's not quite the same this is the new
revised version of the coop a sedan we
tested the CLS 220 with the smallest
available engine a 2.2 litre diesel the
more paranoia the current is to montes
current says that even the smallest
engine still makes a CLS sporty after
all it has 400 Newton metres of torque
even at relatively low rpms more
precisely at 1,400 rpms the 125 kilowatt
4-cylinder diesel engine accelerates the
elegant vehicle from zero to one hundred
and eight point three seconds the top
speed is 226 km/h
about Nick no by Marcus notes that not
only the COS is diesel but also its
gasoline-powered engine is new the three
and a half litre six cylinder engine and
the CLS 400 is layered by Laird he means
the ancient has two turbochargers that
operate at different engine speeds that
gives the CLS 400 245 kilowatts of power
with consumption at seven and a half
liters of fuel for 100 kilometers not
bad for a gasoline engine in this
performance class but the engines aren't
all that has been revised the automatic
transmissions have been updated as well
rotten altamonte us recalls when
automatic transmissions had three years
then fourth and fifth gears were added
and then the sixth year then a few years
ago seven gear automatics appeared and
now in the CLS Mercedes has installed a
nine gear transmission one might think
that the car is so busy shifting then it
has little power left for propulsion but
that's not the case the speed bands are
just better utilized which increases
fuel efficiency and monta says he hardly
notices the car shifting as he drives
now for the design changes which are
mostly at the front the most important
change is the optional multi-beam LED
headlights which offer a broader and
more even illumination of the road and
no glare to blind drivers coming the
other way and that means greater safety
the grill and front bumpers have also
been slightly reworked the sideline is
almost exactly the same the sweeping
fold over the rear fender is still a
striking detail on the CLS little is new
about the rear either
a glass sunroof is optional and makes
the interior feel very roomy
but he's on come on Mathis is Mercedes
has completely changed the dashboard
integrating a free-standing monitor in
it our car test to prefer the earlier
built in recess monitor but concedes the
taste different and the new version does
have the advantage that later larger
monitors could be installed without
altering the whole dashboard dacia hataf
unified in 40 that's much better choice
of aluminium con una that's complete ama
tu empresa Fenlon unchanged as the good
legibility of the instrument cluster
with a display in the middle of the
speedometer and what more could one want
an interior craftsmanship the four
bucket seats have the right amount of
firmness and their lateral support gives
passengers of feeling of security
all in all it's a harmonious whole with
a price starting at fifty-four thousand
euros so it's not bargain basement but
for a design oriented buyer it's
certainly an alternative to the e-class
or even the larger s-class de cartas de
Montes Mercedes tark of a new generation
seems exaggerated the exterior design
has hardly changed just a little in the
headlights and radiator grille the
interior has a new dashboard and there
are new engines and transmissions but
then why should Mercedes drastically
change a winning team 120,000 units of
the CLS has been souls in two thousand
ten thousand my cycle for the extreme of
our body Hawkinson
just drive your car into the parking
garage dusseldorf airport and you might
think you'd entered a set of Star Trek
but these luminous panels are not
science fiction they're already science
fact passengers can just leave their car
and head for the terminal it's valet
parking courtesy of Ray the robot
Thomason's is the bay admirer of several
transport systems explains that this
system is easily installed in parking
garages without elaborate additions his
company has developed a robot a
driverless transport system that picks
up the cars and moves them on the ground
without special installation wasn't
silly endless thanks to the slim
construction of the robot the cars can
be parked closer together using the
garage space up to sixty percent more
efficiently ray can adjust a car is to
practically any size and with the help
of a computer find the optimal spot for
every model
the system also functions as a network
where several parking robots work
together to organize parking for large
numbers of vehicles they administer the
parking spaces putting some in long-term
storage or moving cars to the front when
required as king Myra says the system
works with almost any kind of car with
the exception of a few older American
models that are too long the system can
currently handle ninety-eight percent of
cars any model that you would normally
drive into a parking garage can be
parked here Conan m'k'n'zy hell [ __ ]
airports are interested in investing in
these futuristic garages because they
offer great benefits to travelers on
this question yet Airport head Thomas
Naga explains that the idea is to
address customers who want to park their
cars quickly to make their trips as
efficient as possible because the garage
is so close to the terminal passengers
are just steps away from the check-in
area and their flights second by jean
time adult effect a fluke six of the
robotic parking spaces are currently
available for passengers and they've
aroused lots of interest this man says
he gladly used the system if it makes
economic sense the parking robot only
adds 50 cents to the normal daily
parking rate of twenty nine euros ray
maneuvers around the deck with high
precision with the help of a measuring
razor and reflectors placed
strategically on the walls the flight
database tells the robot which vehicle
to bring out next based on the scheduled
time of arrival or a message from a
smartphone ray has the car ready for its
owner right on time
the MINI Countryman has had a facelift
in addition to certain visual
modifications its range of engines has
also been revamped for gasoline and
three diesel engines offer power between
72 and 160 kilowatts skid plate elements
for the front and back are no standard
equipment in the all wheel models and
Germany prices for the countryman
started twenty thousand four hundred
euros with its 108 model pujo has now
moved into the city colour segment six
design themes and three color
combinations allow lots of leeway for
customization buyers can choose between
two efficient 3-cylinder engines with 51
and 60 kilowatts the price for this
little cujo starts at 8890 euros in
Germany
it's been watching an earphone a second
op is testing the new skoda octavia
station wagon today near Hamburg the
Scout version may not look new but it is
sasha says we can see he's already
test-driven it and he's pretty satisfied
it's dust cooking once it's on scoot is
on TV a scout station wagon will go on
the European market and late August it
isn't just out to impress like some cars
that look like off-road vehicles the
Scout has off road technology and design
the cuff Tim sasha says the new
holodecks 5 coupling distributes power
to all four of the scouts wheels as
needed the Haldex 5 traction system
makes the Octavia Scout outstanding when
off-road power is always distributed
optimally among all the wheels so that
the Scout can climb steep slopes even if
they are not paid
the Scout can also handle steep downhill
rides
but I bacup [ __ ] sasha says the car has
no special support going downhill so the
driver has to do the braking himself but
at least in this case that's no problem
above the headlights the body hasn't
changed oscoda earns the Scout emblem
with its off-road capabilities
under the headlights and taillights the
transition to the bumpers has been made
even more angular
the wheel rims fit that pattern to
the core sasha says the biggest
differences between the normal station
wagon version of the Octavia and the
Scout version are the large air intakes
in front and a skid plate the rear also
has a skid plate on top of that says
Sasha a scout can pull up to two tons
for example a horse trailer this towing
power is great for vacations too we
tested the Scout with a most powerful
diesel engine one that puts out 135
kilowatts thanks to its direct shift
gearbox the scouts prints from 0 to 100
km/h at 7.8 seconds the largest diesel
consumes exactly as much fuel as the
smallest 5.1 liters per 100 kilometers
skoda is working to reduce fuel
consumption in all its engines
matawan the car tester says the new
version is optimized fuel consumption by
up to twenty percent by means a brake
energy recuperation and the automatic
start/stop function automatic the check
machine drives through small patches of
water in stride the under body is
completely shielded protecting the
machinery from stones and branches the
brakes have additional protection to the
Scout has 33 millimeters more clearance
than the standard Octavius station wagon
deaths easing travel on rocky roads and
steep inclines the interior is typical
Octavia and well crafted the scouts logo
is found in various spots
the Scout combines a number of good
characteristics generous space more
safety on the road off-road capabilities
and very good towing power and yet its
needs at the fuel pump are modest and at
thirty two thousand six hundred fifty
euros in Germany with the most powerful
engine it's reasonably priced yet my
there's a saying that the cleaner a car
looks after off-road duty the better it
was our test car is pretty
mud-splattered our card tester had a
great time flowing through the
countryside with a Skoda Octavia Scout
station wagon so he recommends it for
anyone who wants a vehicle that can
really go off road
for decades the classic VW bus lovingly
known as the bully in Germany has been
an icon of 1960s flower power life on
the road and freedom 405 VW buses of all
generations from the t1 to the t5 have
converged on the Baltic Sea Island of
fame on for the midsummer bully festival
the beach party lasts for four days the
fun of it is simply getting together
with people and driving around this is a
piece of German culture cultural who
this time it's part of my life I drive
it up stop to go surfing and at these
meets you see people you know it's a
little community familia notification
with friends and family you sit together
and chill out talk about VW buses we
talk shop oh my you're having an
original or one that's been modified
it's just fun to be with all these
people hardly any other van of its class
is as versatile it can be individually
customized for travelling hobbies or
leisure activities a custom-built
extended rear for extra cargo space or
it can be converted into a pickup we've
converted the vehicle to be utilitarian
but also usable as a leisure time car
I've customized them professionally for
27 years so I made a career of my hobby
and now I've made a hobby of my career
again now it's back to just being my
hobby this is easily hits it a highlight
of the festival is the parade the
participants form a convoy and drive
over to the mainland and through the
villages along the coast wherever they
go people are excited to see them it's
all about seeing and being seen
if flood of quality people are happy to
see you and they way with big grins on
their faces I don't think any other car
makes for such thrilled and happy faces
and that's somehow satisfying you put so
much effort money and love into it and
then when you get responses like this
when you get all these smiles and thumbs
up it's beautiful become justice m'angil
olivia tanis Tom Warren Zubov should
it's one big celebration of the VW bus
and its fans but not everyone here has
been bitten by the VW Bug some are here
with other mates we've converted our
Mercedes Sprinter into a camper van
we're looking for ideas for small cars
our sprinter is fairly small because we
travel to Norway a lot so we're here to
gather ideas and there's no shortage of
inspiration and ideas all around
some of the buses have undertaken a long
journey back to their German roots this
is a lexicon this is a 1995 Mexican
build t to see it was built in Mexico
until nineteen ninety five then
production went to Brazil you can fall
in love with a piece like this you have
to put something into it it's been
restored twice but it's a true friend a
member of the family when taken care of
VW buses just seem to keep going and
going and going
as a member of the family the VW bus
needs its tender loving care this is
where the girls from the car wash come
in they clean wax and polish the paint
till it shines just look at this darling
it's magnificent while some keep
scrubbing others kick back in their
buses on mobile cafe
yet another infamous team the bus was
going to be cannibalized but it was
still in good condition and we thought
we had to do something with it we had to
give some thought to what we wanted to
do sometimes admissibility unfuckin in
germany the vehicle inspectors have to
approve all vehicle modifications the
inspectors folded everything out and
folded it all back in again and made
sure it wasn't too wide we're not
allowed to drive on public roads like
this but once everything is stowed away
as classified as a load and that makes
it street-legal like a typical VW bus
fan they bring their own folding sofa to
the party there's still enough for other
parties on other beaches
today Christophe Bauer is going to show
us a luxury convertible from the 1930s
introducing the horse 930 V when it came
out in 1937 the German auto industry was
in a serious crisis
that's a team under Isaac in 1937 the
economic situation in Germany was
anything but Rosie says her car tester
with the government gearing up for war
the scarce resources available all went
towards building up the military the
economy was bled dry so basically it was
a really unfavorable time to launch a
luxury car with the horse 930 v eight
cylinders almost five metres long and
weighing it in almost two tons the horse
930 V boasted impressive stats and it
cost a pretty penny too
since I was nine this floor window
convertible as it was called had a price
of ten thousand one hundred of ice
months and okla capitaine convertible
conscious 4300 of ice marks less than
half but the horse still managed to sell
pretty well over 2,000 units were made
through 1940 and most of them were the
convertible variety acabo valiante
Porsche had a tradition in luxury car
making the company was founded by
engineer August Horch in 1899 in 1909
the founder left due to internal
wrangling he set up a new firm Porsche
surname means listen and German which in
Latin translates as howdy in 1932
Porsche and Audi joined with two other
makes to become Auto Union but the horse
brand retained its superior status
strictly speaking the 930 V is a kind of
horse for beginners under the long hood
was a successor to the first German v8
engine built in 1933 repeated increases
in displacement from 3 to 3.8 meters
gave the engine of very respectable
performance
most products the horse was originally
conceived of as a classic
chauffeur-driven sedan explains
Christophe but a one of them like this
one were made with a short wheelbase
which makes sense of the owner is
driving himself at the front we had a
wonderful v8 engine with a 3.8 litre
capacity and 92 horsepower and it's
still a cool Cruiser today ee 20 Cal
personal seal super they investigate
in 1938 over twenty percent of new car
registrations in Germany in the three to
four liter displacement class were
horses the brand was market leader in
the luxury class
a tech olacak oh it's big rival in 1930s
was Mercedes but they were in a
different category in terms of both
horsepower and price Porsche was loved
for the understated elegance no frills
no gimmicks just solid and unobtrusive
in this case for the body from
convertible specialist glaza as for the
workmanship it is beyond reproach glaiza
want rusty five items call it a turn key
Senate eligible yeadon trifle a Hearton
here finds this leader finds a rush
leather sumptuous wood trim and a roof
that is easy to operate plus it's
waterproof it is something you couldn't
take for granted back then the radiator
grill bears the four rings of auto union
now outies local of course but as if to
underline horses special status the
makers covered the cars with their logo
a crown letter H two-door or four-door
four or six seats with or without a roof
there was a wide range of versions to
choose from if you are willing to pay
enough you could basically get where you
want it
pop the hood and you'll find a robust v8
engine with a 3.8 liter displacement one
strength of the engine is high
elasticity it's not keen on high rev
levels but the eight cylinder unit does
kick in really strong as soon as you put
your foot on the gas at the white fun a
forge says Christophe is pure luxury you
float over the road carefree the
suspension is incredibly comfortable and
if you want to pick up the pace and the
first autobahns had already been built
by then this little knob engages fifth
gear taking you to 130 kilometers an
hour Wow because but those drivers
putting the horse through its paces
could expect to pay the price at the
pump this baby chugs down an average of
19 leaders for every 100 kilometres a
far more aerodynamic successor was
planned but World War 2 precluded its
production
the horse 930 V is a fantastic car says
Krista with one major problem it came
out at the wrong time in 1938 only a
very limited elite could afford this car
but it still sold relatively well and
the horse 930 V was its era's most
successful German v8 luxury car it
definitely deserves a place and this
pantheon of automotive classics these
days by the way such a convertible in
good condition will set you back around
160,000 euros